Kevlar fun you haven't played
PewDiePie's pixel Inge it's out it's
finally out I'm so excited obviously I'm
gonna be biased obviously I love this
game it's so fun r.i.p PewDiePie Stuber
simulator it's been real our minds have
been working on this game for a long
time we wanted to make a game that was
more competitive this time we haven't
launched ranking yet it was coming very
soon I will do a couple of ranked
matches later but basically the gist of
the game is turn-based realtime strategy
i love pokemon pewdiepie it's really
weird but it's super fun and it really
works and i think what i really like
about it is that you can play it
single-player and multiplayer whatever
way you like to play I'll do an easier
level just to demonstrate okay let's do
a map I'm already completed the greatest
game of all time this story's really
funny and really cute and obviously
there's some very old-school PD PI
references but it's very wholesome you
know I really like it so I deploy my
pick slings I have Edgar who does a lot
of range damage and Maya which is good
for healing when the orange bar fills up
that means they're ready to attack and
when the yellow dots are ready
that means the special attack which
charges up you can obviously change in
and switch positions I'll show you that
in a second what a nice time for me to
do it I tend to just focus on trying to
get down one
I want my I have to take more damage
dive switcher in the middle do some
tanking as well that barrel is gonna die
soon but I also really want the other
one to die so I'll do my special attack
it does that one run I have a speaking
way to my tree if you haven't played
this game before more more generically
all the animations are hand-drawn which
i think is so cool I think that's a
really really cool thing that I'm really
proud of and it looks so pretty this
game this bro town which is the first
area is literally just scratching the
surface of the game there's so many more
pretty and cool pixel ings and areas and
things in general that are just I don't
know it's just so impressive to have a
mobile game that actually does it took a
lot a lot of work to get this hey my
special attack flawless Sarah that
that's what I like to see so you level
up your pixel ings you can find food and
feed them to level them up and if you
find more of extra you can level them up
you'll find your favorite ones and then
you'll keep leveling those up basically
so here are my pick slings right now
this is my rooster there's different
types Maya heals randomly husky huge
heavy attack
and guys okay they're so cute basically
is random wish pixels you will get I'll
open some now just for the sake of it
hey I got Burke I already got Berg and
Edgar cute okay I got some bugs
alright this is the first time I spent
anything in the game you really don't
have to it's just to show off more stuff
I stayed up all night yesterday to
playing I've lived it
I'll legit addicted to my own game okay
I know I'm just talking too much it's
not alright let's open that chest see
what we did alright
ayyy boots gotta I think that means I
can level up boots now because I have
many of him that's right rank up close
nice
what is that we got a rare nice hey we
are Shannon hi cool I never used these a
goddamned I know who I'm replacing
sorry you're sexy but Shannon is better
so yeah this is bro town it'll go all
the way to 75 and then there will be
more and more and more we have a ton of
stuff planned and yeah the point is to
collect them all this is obviously
that's defano and that's marcia okay
those are all the ones you can get in
bro time and then there's Floatopia
there's many different ones that's gonna
come up if you get stuck in the game a
really great way and really the point of
the game is to play ranked I played a
couple before and I won let's see if I
can do that again it'll be embarrassing
my second little game alright here we go
we're playing against Mick qql Mick you
Carol you're about to get schooled
against the P man imagine playing
against Barry PI and not even knowing
about it go Shannon alright his Eagle is
about he's got sponsor eagle so he's
probably pretty good
level 42 sponsor you go how am I gonna
beat that you play dirty okay that's a
lot of damage nice I feel like I should
just try and prevent sponsor ego from
attacking honestly he's the one that's
gonna do all the damage okay so I'm
gonna stun sponsor eagle it's gonna be
my strategy we'll wait for him to attack
nice these oh he's as well
cheeky seats sponsor you'll didn't
attack that we prevented a lot of damage
oh you're making moves huh you're making
moves eh
so do I I make moves too I move things
sponsor eagle fund his stuff is a lot
higher level than me this is not fair
alright let's move him before the attack
nice I need sponsor able to die I forgot
to move damn it alright we'll do another
stunning
oh that's a lot of damage that's a lot
of damage but can we finish him that's
fine if you want to do that move I don't
mind this is very even I think he's done
more damage than I have yes
that was awesome okay there's hope
oh god now it's double damage oh this
could end anyway I don't know oh he's
got shields I need to what do i do what
do I do what I do I'm freaking out yes
oh my god that damaged I'm nervous
super 69 that's it big this is so close
come on I see shields
oh that's bad he's dead stupid shields
yeah but I got this
he doesn't do nearly enough come on come
on come on this is so intense
yes - alive come on double damage triple
damage gonna start soon yes
yeah you're going down embarrassing
take your high levels and get out of
here my day my game
very nice that was legit satisfy I was
nervous the game is obviously support
this is what we wanted like competitive
gameplay I think that's super fun on
mobile games cuz it's casual it's light
and but it's still like intense which I
really really like
I think they nailed it every time me and
out of minds play against each other was
so fun hopefully soon we'll be able to
you can battle against your friends and
stuff like that but yeah I'm just super
proud of out of mines for making such a
cool game all the feedback that I've
seen it's been really really positive it
seemed like you guys really liked the
game as well which makes me really good
obviously the game is free so obviously
comes with packs and stuff like that
whatever your opinion is on that I don't
know but I'm glad we're able to have it
free I think it's cool
considering how much we spent making
this I think it's pretty fair okay it's
so funny watching Marcia's reaction to
the game and all the creatures and yes
we did release this game at the same
date as Pokemon because you know what we
were confident that this was gonna be
the greatest game a long time that's how
we knew hey kids you want to not pay for
Pokemon this game is free it's out it's
free it's that big damn that's a lot of
damage all right sweet Shannon saw
Shannon you need a swig thank you there
it is
boom it up Tennant ah Shannon you suck
so if any character dies so you don't
get 0 deaths which is like I obviously
want 3 stars on everyone so I already
messed up but it's still worth
continuing to get the exp in the points
I always finish up anyway god you're
damaged son
you call that damaged I think we notices
well or they told me at least when
testing is that if you're good at the
game if you were actually good at it you
should be able to win every time no I'm
not good against other people I mean on
the same sort of rooster and there you
have it double damage perfect time very
nice
I don't want very nice I want zero
that's what you can have rainbow name in
Minecraft oh nice quest is a great way
to level up yourself as well definitely
do quests forgot we had that you can
boost if you want if you feel like it
dude Shannon it's gonna destroy I shall
have a lot myself as well that's such a
weird thing to say do I need to grow out
my beard now to play this game properly
I feel like ice no one talking to my
guild everyone was talking before I was
so cute what can get Jennifer I didn't
realize nice good old Jenny's money you
can only have two rares that makes sense
so you can't just get all the
overpowered ones
alright let's do one more okay here we
go I guess I go first okay all right
what was that damage Weiss is actually
closed yes oh my god am i doing it yes
two more oh come on what come on
Jennifer yes oh no no no come on more
damage Oh Jennifer you're babe triple
that all I wish you could trash talk
[Music]
oh yes
level up I think it Oh medium chest
that's good give me that chance
open that chest what do we got slippy
yes best game of all time
we're almost there come on Edgar now
it's not the time to eat random trying
oh just wait until you see what else we
haven't started so really good stuff
Hey delete base got Jennifer vs.
Jennifer Beauty primers is PewDiePie
moving it away I love that a tiger
footage which PewDiePie is the stronger
predefined damage
switch these come on come on dang it
we missed the crit and we throw it back
that's right yeah Jennifer my babe I
love her so much she's so beautiful in
this game when she's on my side oh my
god see how the mechanics are just
simple but it's still so competitive
with keeping track on your bars you can
check our enemy's bar trying to fake
them out trying to understand what
they're doing
I think it's cool okay I think all right
Jennifer you tanked enough come on
that's it look at that beautiful weight
he has more PD pious that's illegal
watch this sayonara beauty son yeah man
I can't believe how lucky I was that
last game nice three stars baby zero
decks thanks right all year oh good I'm
so glad to finally be able to play the
game cuz I've been playing it but every
time they update them to a new version
it always resets the game for me I think
that's good for now I obviously want you
guys to have fun with it download it
it's out on Android and iOS check it out
thanks for watching bye bye we're all
excited about the new game that's coming
out and I can't wait to play it it
starts with the letter P can you guess
what it is here with E PI pick selling
of course what you thought it was
Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
you